the hauler parade made its way down the
strip a little bit earlier tonight that
means race week is cranking up at the
las vegas motor speedway and our ron
futrell is camping in the infield with
hundreds of dedicated racing fans and he
shows us what it's like before the races
even start
all right hi everybody it is nightfall
here at the las vegas motor speedway
we're in the johnny walker rv i have i
burnt the burgers earlier today but
there's there's another day tomorrow
i'll have another opportunity to mess
them up again but we're going to show
you inside the rv here some of the stuff
that we got okay the amenities here are
absolutely spectacular got the big
screen tv
showing the strongman competition going
on right now along you got a microwave
big fridge
gas stove a gas stove okay not electric
gas stove that's sort of nice here and
then
right over here my favorite feature in
this is oh the fireplace
and it works it's it's an electronic
fireplace but heat still comes out of
that so that's nice jbl sound system
it's pretty good and you couple that
with these cookies that were sent over
to us from the folks at las vegas motor
speedway today so it's uh
we're working hard
out here to put this all together
tomorrow's going to be another big day
out here there's a truck race at six
o'clock and then of course on
saturday you're going to have the um
xfinity race and then on sunday will be
the nascar cup race so a lot happening
out here and we're going to show you all
over the infield i'm ron futrell live
local now